how Bad's this bailout well it's really
hard to tell it's a big fat document 400
something page is full of bells and
whistles for special friends and favors
the worst part of is I don't even really
know what the Treasury Department's
going to do except it's supposedly gonna
buy some stuff
try to recapitalize banks etc what are
the odds are gonna do well very low
obviously they are part of the reason
we're in this mess today being the
people who have set up the rules and
regulations of the current system which
was designed to try to get people to buy
a lot of houses with other people's
money and we've seen how that's turned
out and so I'm extremely pessimistic
I'm particularly pessimistic about what
it's going to do to the capital and
financial system in the United States
which basically channels savings into
the hands of creative people we have
broken a number of the feedback loops
that made that system work well on some
I'm quite concerned about the next o
generation if we're gonna fix this mess
I think it's important to understand how
we got to where we are today the
standard answer is it was greed run amok
markets don't work we've learned our
lesson Milton Friedman was wrong
deregulation was a mistake and it's time
to get the government involved well
there was a lot of greed there always is
Wall Street is based on high yield
that's the whole idea
but it's about prudent risk the
interesting question for me is what role
did government play in encouraging
risk-taking that was with other people's
money there been a button there's a
bunch of stuff we've done over the last
10 years that has artificially driven up
the price of housing Fannie and Freddie
the government-sponsored agencies which
had it implicit now it turns out actual
guarantee to use our money to bail out
their mistakes they were pushed
consistently over the last 10 to 13
years to spend more and more of their
money buying up mortgages of low-income
people which is a lovely idea but as
eventually what that has done at a
minimum is pushed up the price of
housing and the demand for housing we
also had the Community Reinvestment Act
yes it was passed in 1977 so people said
I couldn't have anything to do with it
but as you'll read if you look around
the Clinton administration strengthened
it and greatly increase the pressure on
banks to make loans to people they
normally wouldn't make loans to often
backed by
Freddie and Fannie that was hundreds of
billions of dollars that also pushed up
the demand for housing we also had the
1997 Taxpayer Relief Act which it made
an enormous reduction in the exclusion
of capital excuse me an increase in what
people could exclude from capital gains
expand it to rental and vacation houses
which also bushed up the band for
housing and then we had it 2001 and 2002
thousand and two and three the lowest
interest rates in 40 years and a lot of
those were for adjustable rate mortgages
which are now coming due as rates go
back up so government did a bunch of
things that made housing much more
expensive and it otherwise would be if
you owned a house that was lovely you
felt yourself getting richer and richer
but that allowed people to feel very
good about lending money to highly risky
people as long as housing prices are
rising they're less likely default with
no money down if you put no money down
in housing prices fall or if the economy
hits a bump you're going to see a much
higher default rate and that's what is
spinning out of control
so it's a combination of factors it's
not Fannie Mae by itself it's not the
Community Reinvestment Act by itself
it's not the capital gains tax cut by
itself it's not the cuts in tax rates by
themselves but those along with some
innovation in in securitization and Wall
Street which had many good things about
it unfortunately is put in a present
predicament what we're doing now is
trying to figure out how to recreate
that wonderful artificial market for
housing instead of saying let's learn
our lessons and not have people spend
other people's money it's a mistake well
what should we expect from the bailout
going forward is an interesting question
it is I think the most important part is
not the budgetary part although it's
actually large enough that the budgetary
part actually should be paid attention
to we're not very good at saying no in
the United States or in Iraq okay we'll
do that two hundred billion dollar
bailout of Fannie and Freddie oh that's
a good idea
seven hundred billion dollar bailout of
the rest of the financial sector that
too what are we going to cut earmarks
that's 17 billion dollars last year or
Barack Obama courageous maverick himself
wants to cut contracting expenditures by
the federal government by 10 percent
called a slash that is 40 billion
dollars in a three trillion dollar
budget so far in counting
that's not even a deckchair on the
Titanic we have to do something serious
on the budgetary side but the budgetary
side let's put that to the side let's
just look at the incentives that the
current bill apparently does what it
does is basically said it says if you
made a big mistake and you bought a lot
of stuff that turned out to be junk
we're going to buy that from you at a
price that it's not worth today to make
sure that your balance sheet can get
healthy and the financial system will
regain liquidity the effect of that of
course is to say to future investors
don't be as cautious as you otherwise
would be because there's a chance we
will bail you out
so the real cost of this to me for the
American economic system or standard of
living our way of life is we have said
to people risk-taking is not as risky as
it used to be that's a mistake
it's a horrible mistake and it will it
lead basically to a lower standard of
living down the road because investing
will be more Cavalier and less prudent a
lot of people want more regulation are
the same people who want less money in
politics and it's a noble goal less
money in politics fewer special
interests people often forget that the
reason that special interests are so
powerful in politics is because
government has so much power has so many
goodies to hand out so if you're handing
out goodies people pay a lot of
attention to you it's just the way of
the world it's true in the private
sector and especially true in the public
sector so if you're spending three point
one trillion dollars and if you are
writing the regulations that affect
people's live strangely enough people
have an interest in trying to get you to
change those rules to help them rather
than helping others when people come
behind to me they want to get money out
of politics I always say make government
less powerful works like a charm
and as our governors got more powerful
yes money plays an increasingly
important role and it's not a good thing
it's a bad thing I want to see power
decentralized push down to us and away
from them